We previously introduced the Gaussian kernel
and the Gaussian kernel is very frequently
used in image processing because the ability
to smooth the image reduces noise within the
image.
And particularly if we are computing the derivative
of an image noise can be quite significant.
Taking a derivative tends to enhance any noise
that is within the image, so it is important
to reduce the noise in advance and we can
do that by smoothing with a Gaussian.
So the operation of computing an image derivative—we
can express as a convolution between a derivative
kernel D and the input
image I.
And we denote the result as ∇I; that is,
the upside down triangle in front of the I:
represents a derivative of the image I.
And we want to smooth the image before we
apply the derivative to it, so we represent
it like this.
We apply the Gaussian image; we convolve the
Gaussian image standard deviation σ with
the image I, and then we convolve it with
the derivative kernel.
Using the rules of associativity we can rewrite
it so that we apply the derivative kernel
to the Gaussian.
Those two together we refer to as a derivative
of Gaussian kernel.
So convolving DoG kernel with the image performs
both smoothing and gradient computation and
this is what the DoG kernel looks like and
this is its analytical form.
We can compute the DoG kernel using the MATLAB
tool box function kdgauss, where the first
argument is σ and the second argument is
the half width of the kernel.
Now sometimes it is useful to compute the
second derivative, and the Laplacian is an
isotropic second derivative operator.
It tells us where the gradient has got a maximum
value and it doesn’t matter whether it is
in the U- or V- direction.
The notation IUU indicates the second derivative
in the U direction.
IVV is the second derivative in the V direction.
We can compute the second derivative by convolving
the image with the Laplacian kernel and the
Laplacian kernel is simply a symmetric 3 by
3 matrix shown here.
And in the MATLAB tool box we can obtain a
value of this kernel using the function klaplace.
Computing a secondary derivative is even more
noise enhancing then the first derivative,
so it is even more important that we smooth
the image first.
So we can pull the same trick that we did
with the first derivative, we write here the
secondary derivative operation as the Laplacian
kernel convolved with the input image, but
if we smooth the image first with a Gaussian
kernel using the rules of associativity, we
can rewrite this as a convolution of the Laplacian
kernel with the Gaussian kernel and that is
then convolved with the input image.
The convolution of the Laplacian and Gaussian
kernels is referred to as the Laplacian of
Gaussian kernel and it is shown here.
It has a shape that is often referred to as
a Mexican hat, sometimes it is referred to
even as the Mexican hat function.
It is an upside down Mexican hat; we can see
here its analytic form and we can compute
this kernel using the tool box function klog,
where the first argument is the standard deviation
and the second argument is the half width
of the kernel.